first you must ask yourself are you  wealthy super truth of the world is that  most games someone to win someone think  of this as fairy tale that actually  happened there's confusion over who has  to pay so they drowned you and 20 other  innocent people and somebody's making  money from it no it goes back to this  law firm mossack fonseca so what happens  next what do we do next  [Music]  all I did was try and send money it's a  scam that goes from Houston to the West  Indies to some Bank who knows where  they're getting away with murder which  is bad big bid is such a big word for  being such a small  how does it all work bribery corruption  money lost millions and millions and  millions of dollars  somebody has to sound me along how the  [ __ ] is my money most of the time we  don't even know  you  you